de prix cassés dans une casse auto 15
euros pour un rétroviseur une portière
ou même un moteur complet c'est le
concept des deux jours de foire organisé
à Gièvres auto 41 15 ans déjà que les
particuliers les professionnels
profitent de ces bonnes affaires un bon
plan pris d'assaut en septembre
d'inflation ambiance sur place avec
Clémence d'OSC
[Applaudissements]
top départ d'un marathon un peu
particulier celui d'une foire à la pièce
auto capot moteur injecteur les pièces
non garanties sont toutes à 15 euros
seule condition venir avec ces outils et
les détacher soi-même une fois des
pièces pour un Mazda Toyota mon avis
c'est des modèles et puis bah pour
réparer la mienne donc j'ai un Dacia
chez moi donc j'ai une 206 moi chercher
un pare-choc sur une Focus
échange des ailes peu importe ça monte
alors une planche arrière de classe A
mon collègue un compteur de camions et
puis là on va refaire un tour sur
d'autres véhicules bon plan pour les
Brico du dimanche et même pour les pros
armés de leurs outils les clients s'en
donnent à cœur joie sur les 500 voitures
et scooters proposés par GF auto 41 un
événement façon casse d'antan qui séduit
à l'époque ça a démonté comme ça
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tout est
structuré les pièces sont démontées
informatisées vendus sur les sites
internet donc là on retrouve vraiment
cette énergie du départ mais on aime ça
on attirer des clients il y a un
challenge sur le côté social et
économique une demi-heure après
l'ouverture les premiers passages en
caisse s'effectue résultat des courses
des brouettes bien remplies pour un prix
dérisoire par choc phare de 306 et un
attelage de trafic et vous avez fait ça
en 30 minutes apparemment j'ai pas
regardé
une plage arrière des boutons neufs neuf
pièces de nouvelles carcasses sont
gardées au chaud pour le deuxième jour
de cette fois au mécano elle réunit
chaque année près de 3000 personnes